so I'm gonna give you another approach
and my other approach my second one
rather comes from the fact that this
number we just got here
this number here well this number makes
me suspicious forty-five thousand three
hundred sixty and maybe some of you have
noticed that this is a suspicious number
because it's related to our first
solution the one with no restrictions
what is the relationship between this
number one we just got
and the original it's exactly half
exactly half in mathematics as you know
things are never coincidences why should
it be exactly half well I'm gonna give
you another argument I could call this
anything but I'm gonna call it an
argument from symmetry okay you could
also call it an argument from the
compliment okay now so the neuro now
we're trying to work out can we think
about and same week every other actually
we're trying to work out how can we
think of this in terms of a confident
you know how the compliment can often be
a really useful thing in probability to
so unlock what's going on right can I
use that here well look carefully at the
wedding the question for me we look
carefully at a reader it says how many
ways can you place it so that the letter
n is to the right of D is that correct
letter n is to the right of D what would
be the complement of that what would be
the opposite of saying that the letter M
is to the right of D it you could set in
two ways you could say the letter n is
to the left of D or you could just um
you just swap the letters right you
could say what's the number of ways that
the letter D is to the right of M okay
now let me ask you this
which of those do you think is easier to
solve D before N or n before D wouldn't
it be the same well it is the same it is
exactly the same and I want to try to
convince you of that I'm gonna use a
classic mathematical problem solving
strategy we should always have up your
sleeve which is to consider a simpler
problem okay let's consider a simpler
problem for instance let's consider
instead of having nine letters let's
consider having say four
okay now the reason why I'm considering
four is because I can exhaustively do
this right I can actually work out all
the ways in which what do we want the
letter D comes before in I can work out
all the ways and so can you write for
instance if I put the letter D at the
front right how many places can the
letter and go we just went through this
thought before right there are three I
can put it here or I could put it here
or I could put it here
yes if I shift the letter D over once
I've got less options right like so can
you see there's only one more way for me
to do this
there we go those are all the ways
that's it
exhaustively listed right now can you
see beside these six I could put another
six where I just swapped the position of
N and D can you see that like that would
be literally this is the phrase I talked
to you about before there would be
literally one to one for every one of
these valid solutions there will be an
opposite solution which is not that
which doesn't meet our conditions right
so since it's one to one exactly half of
your original solutions will be meeting
the condition that you want okay so I
want you to pay attention to this
expression down here and I want you to
notice how different this expression is
that I'm about to write the number of
ways equals 9 factorial on true
factorial 2 factorial multiplied by how
many of them are ok exactly 1/2 okay now
just just look at those for a second
this has addition in it why does it have
addition we have cases that's why okay
there is no addition in here whatsoever
but go ahead put into your calculator
and you will see that these two things
are equivalent because I've told the
story a different way does that make
sense okay I'm going to tell the story
one more way what am I gonna do here and
run this off
and what I'm trying to do is flex your
muscles for how you can think about a
situation differently because you never
know which one is going to be the most
useful way I need a new whiteboard
marker okay this approach number three
I'm gonna call this one gaps gaps I just
got to load up a diagram for a second
hold on excuse me
[Applause]
okay so you remember before I said to
you a general rule of thumb we call it a
heuristic a general rule of thumb is to
think about all your conditions first
and then sort out the rest of the
letters okay but you don't always have
to do that and I'm going to give you a
way to illustrate that right we've got
to think about the letters D and n right
well what if I thought about them
separately let me show you what I mean
let's think about and you'll see why and
I'd love you to draw this with me let's
think about all of the letters except
for M all the letters except for M one
two three four five six seven eight okay
so I've got eight spots spots you'll see
why I've left them sort of separated in
a minute okay
let's just think about I guess that
would be decision there you go that's
what I'm arranging okay now think back
to the original question if I just place
these guys with no restrictions
whatsoever okay if I said well the
number of ways of doing these guys how
many total objects do I have to place
eight objects so there are eight
factorial ways of doing those but of
course there is still that repetition
that's I'm going to divide UK with that
so this this number of ways I'm going to
fill in all of these different spots is
that okay
now once I have done that I've got to
put the end somewhere okay but where can
the end go what spot could it go into
well it can go into any other and that's
why I've named it this it can go into
any of the gaps right you could put the
letter D so I know that it m rather
between the first and second letter the
second and third third and fourth etc
right you could put the letter n
anywhere in there like I could put it
here or here or here you get the idea
right have I got all the places that I
could position the letter n where are
you pointing we'll are you counting your
County yeah so I've got um that's seven
different gaps right is there anywhere
else that the letter n could go
ah as Paul points out I could also put
it here at the start I could make the
letter M first or I could make it last
is that okay so I could put in any of
those spots
now therefore when I include the N as
well right I can multiply by however
many places I could put the end how many
red gaps have I given you I can count
yes it's going to be nine right is that
okay so I've got nine gaps into which
the end can go but as you've noticed
depending on where the letter D goes
right suppose we place it here okay you
now can't put N in any of those gaps any
of those nine some of them are duds
right some of them won't work you can't
put it here or here or here or here does
that make sense right so you only have
these left over if I move D somewhere
else like say let's move it shifted over
like so again you've now blocked off
some of them right and every time you
reposition D you block off you eliminate
some of the options okay now how many of
them do I eliminate is this argument
quite interneuron that's a way no I
think I did too I mean it did it go to
sleep by itself let's find out yeah
totally went to sleep nevermind that's
okay how many of them are a good nod you
need it actually I want all of you to
see it how many of these are going to be
okay that's why I forgot it's this
that's why I went to sleep everything's
going to sleep on me today mrs. Lee's
that's um there we go
no thanks thanks I wasn't thinking of
that before but I am now here we go
is it warming up campitos
haha success okay you need to wait for
the colors to come in so what are we
looking at here right we're looking at
in a similar way to the first way we
solve the question we're looking at all
the cases but I just want you to notice
and here comes the color right these 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 these represent the gaps
right the nine gaps that I could put
them in to you but do you see half of
them the green ones half of them are
a-ok right they position n after D which
is what we wanted right it's what we
wanted but half of them are not like can
you see why it has to be half because
you're always blocking off more as you
go from left to right right so exactly
half of these will be okay exactly half
okay now I wonder if you can see the
parallel between this approach three and
approach too can you see in fact that
this guy here this guy here right this
is the way of doing it without
restrictions right it's like oh yeah I
can put them anywhere right but I'm
considering this that I can place the N
in half of those in 9 those gaps but
only half of them are oh okay and that's
why I end up restricting a little bit
okay so the way you retell the problem
gives you all these different ways of
thinking about it some are easier than
others I which one I wonder which one
you prefer probably the quickest one is
approach 2 because it's the only one
which completely avoids cases cases are
not bad but as you can see I have the
working here it's a bit messy sorry
about that cases are by their very
nature they're very long right you have
to sort out all of the different options
and you've got to establish a pattern
and all that kind of thing
so we try to avoid cases if we can it's
just like when you're solving
you know absolute value equations you
can do K it back by cases right but as
the slowest and least efficient way to
do it if you can avoid that if you can
come up with some other kind of argument
it's almost always gonna be more
efficient